[Musique]
à table c'est l'étape des troisièmes
rencontres in cité qui se dérouleront à
saint quentin du 16 au 23 mars sous la
houlette de lionel masse et à le
directeur des thermes de saint quentin
bonjour lionel masser par jour alors je
dis oui c'est le troisième 3ème
rencontre est une cité il ya la première
était pour sa faute de temps l'année
dernière à l'intelligence artificielle
cette année à table kobo d'abord est
venue l'idée de ces rencontres in cité
qui mêle à la fois des tables rondes
avec des chercheurs avec des
spécialistes et puis évidemment une
dimension culturelle avec des spectacles
c'est venu de deux choses d'abord le la
sensation que tout au long de la saison
à travers la programmation embrasse un
certain nombre de thèmes beaucoup de
thèmes sur lesquels elles n'arrivent pas
à s'arrêter à s'appesantir
donc il ya une sorte de frustration et
puis le fait qu'on soit aussi sur un
territoire d'un territoire de recherche
puis koné dans le périmètre de
l'opération d'intérêt national du
plateau de saclay donc la question était
de savoir comment est ce qu'on peut
faire rentrer entrer la parole des
chercheurs dans un lieu qui est un lieu
de circulation de la parole et des idées
six lycées des roses un théâtre et les
chercheurs une autre fois ils sont
devant ils sont dans leur tour d'ivoire
et il montre au contraire qu'ils sont
prêt à s'expliquer et à expliquer les
enseignants ils sont assez friands je
pense que les chercheurs mg chez pas
s'ils n'aiment pas je pense qu'il est
nécessaire qu'il qu'ils échangent avec
leur père qu'ils présentent l'état de
recherche à leur peur je pense qu'il ya
aussi un vrai besoin pour beaucoup parce
que nous essayons quand même très peu de
refus lorsque l'on identifie des
chercheurs qui correspondent à des
thèmes on essuie très peu de refus voire
quasiment aucun ou pour des raisons
d'emploi du temps
bon il ya cette volonté a parlé à
d'autres personnes ou leurs pères et 7
mai si j'allais dire c'est nous et cette
envie cette nécessité de le faire
et puis moi je trouve ça assez
intéressant de leur permettre aussi de
s'exprimer avec un niveau de langage et
qui n'est pas au niveau jargonneux mais
est ce qu'ils savent de voilà qui à la
portée de tous et ça ils savent très
bien le faire alors le thème de cette
année puis l'année dernière c'était
l'intelligence artificielle oz projeter
dans le futur la à table on est pour
acheter plutôt dans le quotidien
l'année dernière avec l'intelligence
artificielle ont été projetés dans le
présent à présent oui mais après et dans
l'ouverture avec raison l'alimentation
des projets on est dans le présent
également dans le futur puisque puisque
c'est une des vraies préoccupations
aujourd'hui on est dans des mutations
sur la question de l'aide de
l'alimentation du manger comme on dit
qui concerne aussi l'avenir de
notre avenir et l'avenir de l'avenir de
la planète c'est à dire c'est pas un
geste le fait le fait de manger geste et
que c'est pas un geste anodin
c'est un étrange anodin et ses cendres
compte de ça c'est un geste qui peut
faire de nous aussi des enfants peut
être pleinement citoyens en ayant une
attention très particulière ce que l'on
mange
alors parce que je dis aussi c'est que
l'alimentation ne se limite pas juste à
la diététique et à l' équilibre
nutritionnel ou goût mais l'alimentation
des répercussions beaucoup plus vaste
donc c'est toutes ces choses là qui sont
qui sont mises en question mise en doute
fort bien toute cette semaine
alors vous avoue travailler pour toutes
ces rencontres et de citer avec avec un
chercheur qui vous aident à
confectionner les tables rondes
notamment cette année c'est un géographe
qui s'appelle gilles fumée pourquoi
géographe 1
c'est par les géographes des cultures
alimentaires mais c'est vrai que bon en
général quand on s'attaque à des sujets
quels que soient les sujets on a besoin
nous notre mais oui c'est le théâtre
donc on a vraiment besoin d'avoir un
d'avoir un appui et surtout quelqu'un
qui ébranle aux certitudes parce que
quel que soit le sujet même si on
reconnaît très peu on a plein de
certitudes
alors dès qu'on commence à travailler
qu'un chercheur il ébranle totalement
nos certitudes idée qu'on commence à
lire ensuite il est important d'avoir un
chercheur qui est une vision à 360° du
thème dont on va traiter et qu'ils
puissent ensuite ouvrir des possibles
sur telle ou telle thématique puis
visibles voilà cette thématique ce n'est
pas la peine de la traiter en aura pas
le temps
ceci est la gué et recentrer le
recentrer le débat
donc si ces rencontres in cité aborde un
certain nombre de thèmes elles sont en
tout cas très nettement resserrées par
rapport à un rapport aux discussions que
l'on a eu au départ avec j fusée voilà
alors il ya beaucoup de tableaux enghien
en a une qui s'appelle par exemple on
est ce qu'on mange on est vraiment ce
qu'on mange
je pensais que mon ordi ce qu'on mange
mais quand on dit on est ce qu'on mange
il ya jan
ça fait résonner plein de plein de
choses il ya des questions qui sont
quand on est ce qu'on mange en fonction
de ce que je mange il ya des questions
qui sont sociales il ya des questions
qui sont culturels il ya des questions
qui sont citoyennes et politiques et en
fonction de ce qu'on mange
on peut aussi ce que j'étais tout à
l'heure manger peut aussi être un geste
un geste politique
donc oui on est ce moment je le fais
enfin ce que l'on mange révèle en tout
cas une grande partie de notre
personnalité ça c'est absolument clair
il ya aussi une table-ronde sur
l'industrie alimentaire alors on dit
beaucoup de choses sur l'industrie
alimentaire
il ya il ya des craintes sur la façon
dont sont traitées un certain nombre de
produits et en même temps il ya des
scandales alimentaires et les églises
mais en même temps on a l'impression
tout ça s'améliore un peu quand même
on est en france quand même
quoi que l'on pense de l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui je pense
voilà fait quand même de très nets
efforts qualitatifs
il y en a encore beaucoup à faire mais
là on va avoir des représentants de
transformateurs de produits
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est d'avoir
d'avoir des points de vue qui sont tout
à fait différent je sais où je me situe
moi mais je lui souhaite
je souhaite laisser je souhaite qu'on
puisse laisser la parole à tous les
acteurs de l'alimentation dont
l'industrie agroalimentaire où se situe
t elle après je pense qu'en france on
est quand même même s'il ya eu des
scandales dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire il y en aura d'autres
qui font beaucoup de bruit je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de problèmes
sanitaires dans les restaurants dans
lesquels on va tous les jours mais ça on
entend tout petit peu moins parler mais
je pense qu'en france on est plutôt
assez bien protégé
je pense qu'il ya une surveillance de ce
que l'on mange la façon dont cet abri
qui est de façon aussi cultivé voilà qui
est plutôt supérieures à celles qui peut
être dans beaucoup d'autres pays
ce qui n'empêche pas parfois à dos de
cheval à voir mais il ya aussi une
dimension après on va parler de la
dimension de l'intérêt mais une
dimension d'éducation dans les pratiques
alimentaires qui sont les nôtres
oui ou ce fait l'une des tables ronde
traitera de la question de où se fait
douce où se forgent le goût mais pour
négligence et du biniou et commence à se
former
comment comment il se trouvait ce qu'ils
se forgent in utero est ce qu'ils se
forgent le le
voilà tant dans la petite enfance est ce
qu'ils se forgent la cantine est-ce
qu'il se forge avec les copains quand on
est adolescent
est-ce qu'il peut évoluer ou pas et puis
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui reste quand on
voyage vers les les c'est assez
intéressant de voir que lorsqu'une
famille quittent un pays où un individu
qui tint pays pour s'implanter dans un
autre pays c'est à dire qui ne voyagent
pas par loisir mais qui voyagent y enfin
qui va se déplacer tout ça pour des
questions de contraintes économiques etc
etc
il faut trois générations pour qu'ils
changent complètement ses habitudes
alimentaires trois générations ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que la culture
alimentaire est souvent une vie web ccc
ce qu'il détient des cantonales a posé
la question en esquivant risque en
mangeant des aliments manche et c'est au
bout de trois générations qu'on arrivera
chan a modifié totalement nos habitudes
alimentaires dans les premières les deux
premières générations voici de
reproduire la première va essayer de
reproduire la la cuisine qu'elle avait
l'habitude de faire ou de manger dans
son pays d'origine
et puis il va y avoir une assimilation
petit à petit il va y avoir une
assimilation mais il va y avoir
également une influence et c'est ça qui
est très intéressant c'est que l'écurie
de s'étonner quand social l'influencent
des apports de l'extérieur d'où ils
viennent sur la cuisine en france c'est
à dire typiquement la cuisine y avait eu
au début du 20e siècle
mais vous savez existe encore des
défenseurs de cuisine française mais
qu'est ce que la cuisine française dlf
si la cuisine team non mais de tout
temps a subi toujours bien sûr mais la
moins suivie influence
c'est vrai que moi que je sais pas quand
j'étais enfant enfin le cboe spa les
gens du nord ne connaissez pas l'huile
d'olive par exemple fait même des
produits enfin est aujourd'hui pour
celle ci non les devants je pense que
tout ça évolue enfin il ya en effet des
choses qui sont arrivées les deux
paraissent aujourd'hui totalement
naturel si je préférais et qu'on ne
connaissait pas un mot avant juste parce
qu'il faut qu'on aborde le
même culturelle est évidemment les
tables rondes vont répondre à ça mais
puisque vous avez travaillé
est-ce que la façon de s'alimenter est
encore un marqueur social
je sais pas si c'est sociale culturelle
mais c'est de ces deux choses
différentes marques g7 ça voudrait dire
qu en fonction de la classe sociale et
de la paix sociale on mange tel sort de
choses je pense qu'il ya une influence
du social bien entendu et de l'accès à
certains produits mais je pense qu'au
delà de ça il ya quelque chose de
culturel c'est-à-dire qu'on se rend
compte qu'il ya des personnes qui sont
d'un niveau social supérieur et des
classes sociales gia et qui ont des
habitudes alimentaires qui sont qui sont
absolument pas saine à dire qu'ils sont
crise ça ne marche pas mieux parce qu'on
est plus riche fois non non non je pense
que c'est une question d'éducation mais
où se forge et l'imitation et d'autres
cultures
mais pour moi c'est plus voilà les deux
centres med mais ce n'est pas que social
matraqueurs marqueur social alors un mot
sur un évidemment dans l'hérault quand
dean cité hier les tables rondes et puis
il ya les spectacles qui vont avec
alors on va participer tous les
spectacles lorsqu'on leur donne on le
retrouve dans mon programme et on le
retrouve sur le site
la cnce alegre thème soit lâché géoïde
encore et si l'appel de christian ubl
qui est qui qui traite de hansel et
gretel vont se retrouver dans un
supermarché joujou vient d'acquérir
rapidement des spectacles de danse c'est
un spectacle de danse mais avec un dj
avec un dj sur scène ils vont se
retrouver dans un supermarché et
naturellement ils vont pas aller au
rayon fruits et légumes ils vont plutôt
aller au rayon confiserie donc c'est
l'occasion
juste après ce spectacle de pleurer et
de traiter de l'anniversaire des enfants
c'est ça passera ainsi qui passera au
crible des anniversaires des enfants qui
est un sujet très intéressant là là on
voit une morue way de la morue de la
morue c'est un spectacle qui a été dit
et écrit qui est
qui est conçu et joué par un comédien
qui s'appelle frédéric ferrer qui est
également agrégé de géographie
sa particularité et qui part active dans
la vie pu voyager en collecte de gilles
film est tout à fait et qui est parti
dans livres dans nos soeurs nos
graphiques s'appelle philippe cury sur
la disparition des ressources
halieutiques
en fait même si le spectacle est
beaucoup plus large que ça il
il pose la question du pourquoi à
terre-neuve qui était un des endroits où
la morue pullulent et pendant les
pendant des siècles
pourquoi est-ce qu'à terre-neuve la
morue est disparu petit à petit de ddo
on a recréé toutes les conditions pour
que l'amour eu reviennent et elle ne
revient pas donc ça veut dire que à
partir du moment où on détruit et ruiz a
détruit l'écosystème billy s'est
terminée il ya envoyé la grande table et
ça c'est une expérience et une
expérience pour quelques happy few
c'est jocelyn binet qui est josselin
mienniel qui est un flûtiste et
compositeur et qui a également était
cuisinier chef cuistot dans de très bons
restaurants ça c'est sa particularité
qui a inventé ce concept où il demande à
un chef et un compositeur de s'entendre
pour créer leur et l'autre une entrée un
plat et un dessert
voilà donc le nom d'un fatras table donc
faut être à ta mère est en fait pendant
le dressage la québec serge houde et
qu'on nous laisse travailler mais je
vous dis juste un mot sur savoir enfin
qui est qui nous buvons alors moi c'est
pas possible parce que c'est un
spectacle dure et un des freins
oui il faut durer je le sais c'est un
spectacle culte pour les amateurs de
20 dire plutôt de vins en biodynamie et
de vins nature et pour les amateurs de
théâtre parce que c'est une c'est une
performance qui peut durer jusqu'à 7h 8h
voilà qui est fait pour le résumer mais
c'est vraiment très très schématiquement
résumé qui est en portraits de vignerons
qui travaillent qui travaille la vigne
en biodynamie donc rencontre insiter 16
au 23 mars notamment au théâtre de saint
quentin mais dans d'autres lieux
yoyo lycée hôtelier de guyancourt à
l'ugc ciné cité il ya plein d'ateliers
qui ont été mis en place par l'atelier
des sciences de saint quentin en
yvelines
il ya des conférences qui sont
organisées par la médiathèque
donc il ya vraiment tous les lieux oui
donc 16 au 23 mars bord on passe à table
maintenant et barlow merci patrice
[Musique]